so taking that experience from that
night where you were with your
flashlight
probably feeling fear exhilaration do
you
impart that same vision to your students
into taking sort of creative leaps that
probably feel scary
to them at first but it sounds like you
trust in your own gut a lot that that's
something that really guides you
that you're very intuitive in that sense
absolutely one of my big missions i
think and the reason why i teach
is not only do i talk because i think
you know everybody can talk
but i also walk that talk and
you know for actors to be proactive
whether it is meant for them
to open a theater or it's meant for them
to open a production company
and shoot lots of movies whether they'll
write it direct them act in them
you know the sense of proactiveness the
sense of you know you can't wait for
somebody
to hand it to you because nobody owes
you anything and nobody's going to hand
you anything
you have to be the one to take that step
and it's empowering to take that step
and important that you should take it
because everybody's sitting on things
that they procrastinate and they know
that they could do
but i think one of the sad sad things in
life is that you look
back on your life and you know that you
could have done it and you should have
done it and
you know and you didn't choose to do it
and so to really make the choice
to get it done